la situation est toujours préoccupante
en birmanie ce mardi une vingtaine de
personnes ont été blessées alors
qu'elles participent à une manifestation
contre le coup d'état militaire du 1er
février trois se trouvent dans un état
critique
le même jour des centaines de personnes
se sont rassemblées dans un petit
cimetière de rangoon pour les
funérailles d'une des victimes tuées par
un tir des forces de sécurité la semaine
dernière nous devons faire savoir qu'il
y a beaucoup de jeunes qui sont contre
la junte et nous devons également faire
savoir à la junte que la birmanie est
maintenant entre les mains des jeunes
ces nouvelles tensions interviennent
deux jours après une journée de
répression meurtrière au cours de
laquelle au moins 18 personnes ont été
tuées selon l'onu
les vagues d'arrestations elles se
poursuivent notamment 26 journalistes
depuis le coup d'état dont dix sont
toujours en détention
le ministre des affaires étrangères
britannique dominic rabe a tenu à réagir
mais c'était notre message est très
clair en particulier après ce que nous
avons vu ce week-end à savoir que nous
devons mettre fin à cette violence
aveugle
ainsi qu'aux ciblage des politiciens de
l'opposition des journalistes et autres
critiques à bien me laisse alors d'après
fait que nous devons mettre un terme à
cette brutalité et ils doivent commencer
à réfléchir à la voie à suivre pour
rétablir la protection démocratique en
birmanie
on dénombre au moins une trentaine de
morts dans les rangs des manifestants
depuis le 1er février
la junte affirme pour sa part qu'un
policier a péri en tentant de disperser
un rassemblement